Next we're going to apply similar edits
to the code that animates the views
alpha to one.
First, go into the ViewController.swift
file and copy this fade in code.
Next, go back to
the UIViewExtensions file and
paste that code into
the fade in function.
Now, just like before we'll replace
imageview.alpha with self.alpha.
Whatever view is calling this
method is represented by self.
And that is the object
we want to fade in.
The next step is the same as well.
We need to pass in the parameters for
duration, delay, and completion.
And then we pass each of those three
parameters to the animate with
duration method.
Last but not least,
we need to alter the code in our
view controller to make it simpler.
Now that we have access to the fade out
and fade in methods from this extension.
So go back to
the viewcontroller.swift file.
And we're going to delete this
call to animate with duration.
Everything up to the completion block.
Let's keep that.
Instead of calling
animate with duration,
we're just going to call fade out.
We'll call it on
the property image view.
The fade out method takes
in three parameters.
Duration, let's do one second for that.
Delay, we don't want to delay,
so we'll put zero seconds.
And then the mysterious
completion closure,
which we kept there from last time.
The first part of the completion
closure can stay in its original form.
But after the image is swapped,
we want to use the method fade in.
Like we did above with fade out, we'll
delete this animateWithDuration code.
Just go ahead and
delete the whole thing.
And in its place we'll put
a call to self.imageView.fadeIn.
Again we'll put a duration
of one second with no delay.
Before we put in the completion
parameter, let's pause for a second and
look at the method signature that
Xcode's code completion brings up.
See how the type of this completion
has a question mark at the end?
This closure has an optional type,
and it's a good thing,
too, because in this case,
we don't actually want anything in
particular to happen when
the fade in method is finished.
We want to be able to pass in null.
And it's fine for
the completion closure to be null,
because it's an optional type.
We want to test this out.
But first we should check in our
storyboard file to make sure that all of
our outlets are connected.
So let's take a look at the image view,
that one's connected.
Let's take a look at the button.
That one's connected.
We should be good to go.
The moment of truth.
We'll go up here to Run.
Press the play button.
Here's our image in the simulator.
And then when we press next.
The image fades out,
and when it fades back in it's
change from sunrise to sunset.